No. Okay, so first order of business. Again, I apologize for the problem that we had with soon.
Back in order of business is make sure you check your member site for announcements. So we have a new announcement today.
So it'll be on the homepage of the member site. So always look at your member site.
The new announcement for today is now. Well, members can schedule appointments with me
through the self-schedule portal. But you have to do it. You have to self-schedule on the member site
on the homepage. It's right below the announcements here. I just took a screenshot of the announcements
on the homepage here. But if you scroll down to be right below that, you'll see where you can schedule
self-schedule with me. Do not self-schedule on our website because that is the higher price
for non-full members. You get a discount. So make sure you do it on the member site where you take
advantage of your discounted prices. So and then secondly, it's if you do not use that self-schedule
if you're scheduled, if you want to schedule one of your free visits. So let's say you just started
with us and you have to schedule to go over your mosaic labs or something. That's included in
your package. You'll have to call in to schedule it or you have to schedule a time to go over your
genetic review. That's included in the package. You'll have to call in to schedule it. So if you're
scheduling one of your included visits, then you'll have to call in. This is for like subsequent visits.
Okay, we have a bunch of questions. So let's get started. Where should I start or what should I first
concentrate on if I'm feeling overwhelmed? We get this question a lot from people when they start
because you do feel like you're drinking from a fire holes and I get it. We don't want you to feel
that way. So number one, if you feel that way, just call us and talk to us. But where do you start?
Well, start with using your right machine. So if all you did was use your right machine, you'd be
way ahead of the game. So I have patients and I probably said this to most people in their case
review. I've had patients over the decades that literally came to me. They're typically men that said,
I ain't gonna change my diet. I ain't gonna take those supplements, but I'll use that machine.
And they got better. So I think that is the biggest key to you improving is using your right machine.
So it's not a magic wand, but that's the most important thing. I can't tell you how many times
that we have had people not doing well and we talked about the phone and they haven't used
their right machine for months. Okay, so it's not gonna help you by not using it. So you got to be
using that. Number two, if you already have your binder, your new start here, you already are your
binder. Start going through it really slowly. It just follow the, you know, follow what you're supposed
to take with your supplements and you're diet. It's not that difficult. You don't need to watch
any videos. You don't need to study the membership. You don't need to learn. You don't need to become
a practitioner. Okay, so some people they feel like that's what they're calling is that God had them
get this disease so that they could learn as much as they could to help others. Well, that's good,
but you got to make sure that that's what you're called to do. If you're feeling overwhelmed, it's
probably because you're doing things you shouldn't do. You need to just rest in the Lord. You take a step
back and go, okay, I'm trying to do things in my own strengths. And that's why I feel overwhelmed.
Well, at least that's what I can say from my experience. I was trying to get a
rife machine connected today and it would not connect. And it was extremely overwhelming for me
because, you know, I'm not a young, you know, chick, you know, have learned computers when I was
a kid either. So, you know, I, this, I'm not extremely technologically, you know, apt. So it was very
frustrating and round and round and round. And then here it was just a chip in the machine that I had
to have to actually get changed. So I kid it. You could get overwhelmed. But when you're out of your,
when you're out of what God has called you to do, that's the biggest reason why you get overwhelmed.
So sometimes you just need to take step back and rest in the Lord and just do the things that you know
to do. Go one step at a time and call us. We'll help you. We'll help call you down. We'll get you
back on the straight there. I don't think in general, it makes me sad when people don't use us.
I feel like God has called us to this. And I would, the answer to this question for Marie,
as well. She's here, not because I'm here so well. She's here because she believes this is a
calling for her. And she loves you guys. And she wants nothing more than to help you and
counsel you and encourage you. And I know you guys have all said to me that that's what you feel
like on the phone or even call it and try to order supplements from Megan and you're so encouraged
because she's such a delight to speak to. That's what we want to be for you. It makes me sad when we
don't hear from people for, you know, a long, long time. And I get it. We're not trying to create
codependency here. But we also want to be here for you. So it makes me sad when we don't hear from
somebody in a long time. And they really should have called us. So don't, don't do that. So you're not
putting us out by contacting us. Next question, you asked us not to run, update frequencies
on the true right. Why is that? Well, because since the company was purchased,
they're not putting out new programs. Back in the day, when Mike owed the company, he would solicit
different practitioners like us to, hey, do you have any new programs that we could add to our list
of all the programs that we have that you found to be helpful, that you created, you found to be
helpful with your patients and such. And then, you know, probably once a quarter, there'd be one or two
programs that were added. And so we always suggested people to hit. There was a button that you can
update frequencies on the true right. And your program would be updated and it would not disturb
any self-created program. So it would disturb the program I created for you.
Well, those days are gone. You know, there's not new programs being made. And there's no sense
updating frequencies. And we've had people hit update frequencies and it messed up our program.
And we had to fix it. So just don't do that anymore. And you don't do that with the Atelier Robin.
There isn't even an update frequencies option with the Atelier Robin. And if you somehow found
it don't do that because all those programs are the Atelier Robin are Mike programs. I wrote them.
So there's I don't have a website where you can update frequencies at this point. So
if there's anything to update, I will send you a flash drive. So next question. I have the B-R-A-F-B-600-E
mutation. Does the cell pathway for this mutation function similar to the K-ROS and the M-TOR in
terms of what specifically stimulates the cancer cell growth? Here's your great video, link
and a graphic on slide two. So I looked up because I wanted to know what graphic this person was
talking about. This is a video that I created. This I'm pretty sure this is the graphic they were talking
about. So this is a graphic talking about the M-TOR pathway. M-TOR is a growth pathway. And there's
all these things in yellow, EMF cell towers, high fructose quartz syrup, fructose high sugar,
iodide rich foods, and then where applicable the gene expression that will make you know give
iodide a greater chance of stimulating growth. With sugar, here you could probably add H-I-F-1-A-G-E
which would cause you know more glucose to stimulate the M-TOR pathway to stimulate growth.
All these things we've talked about over the years you know that can stimulate growth and the reason
they're stimulating the M-TOR pathways just one reason why some of these will stimulate growth.
The metal supplementation we've talked about that it actually stimulates the M-TOR pathway
but it also blocks turns off to the spresser genes pesticides stimulate glutamate stimulate the
M-TOR pathway etc. So is the question was is the B-RAF gene mutation the same as or similar to
the M-TOR pathway. And I'd say the answer would be yes and no. The B-RAF pathway is considered a
tumor oncogene which having that mutation actually stimulates cancer stimulates a cell to go into
rapid replication whereas stimulated M-TOR through anything here doesn't stimulate a cell to go in
to become a cancer cell but it would stimulate a cancer cell to continue to replicate. So yes and
no kind of I would say that the answer to that would be yes kind of it kind of is similar to
the M-TOR pathway. The K-RAF pathway is another pathway it's very similar to that K-RAF pathway is
different in the sense that K-RAF is considered a tumor suppressor gene and defects on that gene
cause a block defects on that gene limit intrinsic pathway through the K-RAF pathway K-RAF gene
intrinsic pathway tumor cell death so it inhibits tumor cell death that's the K-RAF pathway. So if you
have defects on the K-RAF pathway you have inhibition of tumor cell death whereas if you have defects
on the B-RAF pathway you have stimulation of tumor cell growth kind of the same thing but not really
and point is the same thing cancer continues to proliferate but a little bit different mechanism.
Next question does red light therapy stimulate cancer growth and wanted to try to absorb muscles?
No I don't think so there's a lot of you know a lot of promises made like the sale of different
products and red light therapy is one that's probably there's a lot of I don't know how to say it
basically there's a lot of overselling there's a lot of lies told when selling different products
sometimes that are just not right and I know we get questions why don't you sell you know these
different red light therapy things since because I just don't believe in them that they make the
changes that they say they make and you go and you could easily say hey you should look at this study
well this study on this light therapy was done at a much stronger device than the ones that they're
selling for 150 bucks so I just I just don't see and maybe there's a lot of testimonials where
and maybe you'll try it and it'll work really good so I hate to knock something that might work
but I just it's like the people will say I'm using an infrared light because then they'll pull up
these studies on how infrared is so good for you know increase in circulation and killing you know
causing deep heat and actually killing cancer cells and things but then the device itself is not
really infrared there may be one tenth of one percent infrared coming out of the device
so they legally can sell it as an infrared device but it's not truly an infrared device
most of those that you can buy like that actually show their colored light while infrared is not
going to show any light because it's beneath the spectrum so you just gotta be careful with stuff
like that I guess I'm not talking to somebody on this might be listening so let's say I use an infrared
light oh my gosh it helps me so much well then keep using it but I just more skeptical on some of
these things so is there such thing as you see the right for she too much I sleep with it every night
but I use it anytime I'm at whole relaxing oh no there isn't you know there's we have some people
that are so ill that they're just running 24-7 they're running the right you cannot get too much
right unless you're running a lime program that'd be the only thing that you have to be careful with
so anybody that you know I used to sell a lot more rives to lime patients and we just
have not taken lime patients unless they've been referred by a patient we just haven't done that for
a long time and but the rife works fantastic for lime disease but you have to be careful because you
could hurt yourself really easy because it works so good and you hurt yourself by lime as a
gram negative bacteria when you kill it too quickly you still will you liberate
lipo polysaccharides that can thank you sick if you're already done live programs you're running
cancer programs you can't overdo it I'm losing a pound a week what could I do to gain weight while
avoiding dairy sugar and carbs well the first question to ask is are you overweight or underweight if
you're still feel like you're overweight then I would say just continue with your diet if you'd
say no I'd really like to weigh 165 that's where I feel the best and I'm down to 150 now and I'm losing
a pound a week this I'm way underweight okay then you either need to increase your total overall calories
or you need to increase your your complex carbohydrates the only way that you're going to gain weight
is really to eat complex to eat carbohydrates if you eat only protein you will lose weight because you
need carbohydrates in order to gain weight so if you only ate you know let's say you know you're you're
not eating 80 carbs whatsoever the chance you be you know pushing yourself to a state of carcassia or
high so you can't do that you're gonna have to eat some carbs and I would suggest you add or complex
carbs back some oatmeal some potatoes things like that you have to make sure you maintain your weight
wouldn't it be good for everyone to do the Dutch test um no I mean what first of all um you have to
separate the sections so I don't typically recommend the Dutch test for men unless they have extreme
fatigue and that's what they're struggling with some of my line patients I'll recommend the Dutch
test if they're a male um but for a cancer patient typically I don't recommend the Dutch test it's
not going to give us information that we're going to need to make changes um for women it's a
different story fluctuations in hormones affect multiple organs and cause multiple symptoms
whether you have cancer or not so but honestly this question would it be good for every woman
to do the Dutch test well it depends on you know if they have symptoms so if you have a let's say
asymptomatic 25-year-old they're they're not having issues with their periods they're not having
you know emotional breakdown or symptoms or high formal pms or anything like that that I'd say you
don't need to but if you are having any of those things then yes you should at least explore the
the possible imbalance of hormones as positive factors of symptomatic patient that's a female
so then getting the Dutch test would be in order but the person let's say I have cancer and I don't
have any symptoms but I do have cancer a female should I do the Dutch test well it depends on what type
of cancer you have but they have a hormone driven cancer than yes you don't have a hormone driven
cancer than no it also depends on some other factors too you take it you know the everybody doesn't
need to do a test if you're not having any issues let's say my cancers you know um you know
decreasing or I feel like a bit of state of remission that I don't know that we need to do that
but if you feel like the cancer's growing you're trying to get a hold of it and it is a horrible
driven cancer then yes that would be in order I just heard about rejuvenation some say it is great
for healing another site said to avoid it if you have leaky gutter Candida overgrowth if you heard of
this you think it's good or got healing is important to use gluten-free grade or as gluten negligible
in the finished product so rejuvenation because something you make it's a fermented
grain is what it is you ferment a grain now you could use wheat berries you could use oat berries you
could use quinoa if you're going to do it I think it's important to use a gluten-free grain by quinoa
and are there benefits to fermented products yes there's great benefits to
fermented products um if you have yeast issues should you use fermented products no you shouldn't
so yes you should not do it with Candida I wouldn't say that you can't do it with leaky gut um but um
I wouldn't do it with if you have a Candida overgrowth or you think you do and some people do well
with fermented products like that and some people it makes things worse so you just you know
that could give you a clue of what's going on and this person might not have no idea that they
have Candida because they have no you know vaginal Candida they don't even think that they have
a intestinal Candida they ever even had any symptoms like that and then they do a
even drinking a kombucha or something like that because it's on the order of a kombucha
so they drink a kombucha and it really upsets their stomach well that's a hint that you could have
some yeast overgrowth that's that you don't even you didn't even know um so Candida is more
common than you think and the person could have no other external symptoms of Candida you know
they don't have a white tongue or they don't have any vaginal yeast growth or anything like that but
they have a testinal Candida um but I would definitely go with a gluten-free grade is the gluten
in the finished product I would say yes it is still um so I would go with a gluten-free
grade if you're gonna try I just spent 10 days in the hospital because of a doctor who inserted a
stem in my liver and hit my pancreas oh no that's terrible with causing acute pancreatitis
acute pancreatitis if anybody's had that it's the most painful thing oh my goodness it's really bad
that it can lead to very bad complications um you need to be hospitalized you need to
deal with it with antibiotics you just you have to do yourself that else you can do with that it's
very dangerous uh so I'm very sorry for this person I'm now back home but weigh 20 pounds more
because of all the fluids they gave me in the hospital it's miserable how do I get this water
retention to go away they told me that I would pee it out eventually but that hasn't happened yet
can you give me tips so the water and when you're retaining water like this is extra cellular
immediately it's outside of the cells in the extra cellular spaces and the only way to remove it from
your body is to get it into the lymph system and then remember it goes into the lymph system and then
it gets carried to the venous system and then it gets deposited into the urine and through the
kidneys and you get rid of it so I would agree with the doctor that's the only way to get it out
but to get it in the lymph system as fast as you can is to move you have to exercise you have to move
you have to contract your muscles you have to wiggle you have to shake so the action of movement
like on a vibration plate um would help you move lymph um we have some blog posts on lymphatic
congestion and moving lymph there are some holiopaths for lymph uh professional formulas makes a
lymph stem product that people have found to be helpful but motion is the key that's going to be the
absolute key is getting some motion if I'm taking tanka and supplement with milk thistle
we also need to take stay on your phase two well phase two has extensited
and um public reddit and something else I can't remember um so there's just different things tanka
and milk thistle and what's in phase two are all different things that are going to support phase one
two and three in your liver so they're all different so I know if you're on supplement overload
then you can choose to do you don't pause one of them but if you're not it'd be good to help get
things flowing through your liver do you recommend any particular PEMF devices I have been using a small
and expensive and expensive PEMF device called divine and it has helped immensely with the panic attacks
I've been plugged with not be thinking that may be finding another device for breast cancer alive
disease would be helpful for me specifically rather than just uh uh uh right machine if you would
like me to make an appointment to discuss this rather than zoom and be happy to um well first of all
PEMF devices are different because there are some devices that are low ghost devices and that's
what the vibe is the vibe is a low demo dose PEMF device that's you said expensive but the vibe is
is relatively inexpensive maybe that's what you meant um but the problem is the higher ghost
machines are much more expensive so you go up and price based upon the ghost level so like our
professional one that we have in the clinic is what's called is made by pulse and that is um uh about
30,000 ghosts and they're about 40,000 dollars um the vibe is about 600 ghosts and they're about 600
dollars um and you know I know some of you have a beaver at home the beaver is a device that's only
about 1,000 ghosts unfortunately the reason why I don't like the beaver is I think they're way over
price for the ghost level that output is because I think they're about 7,000 dollars um so you really pay
per ghost is what you pay for now is is the higher ghost always better well no not necessarily it depends
on what you're trying to use it for so really the level of ghost output on a PEMF device really defines
the benefits of that device and what you would use it for the reason why I got the high ghost unit is
because I was doing it for cancer align patients and you really want high ghost output the low
ghost devices are not going to really be you know helpful for a cancer patient deal they can help
with some secondary effects and you know they can actually help with with vagal stimulation and I think
that's what you're getting is the vagal stimulation benefits of a low ghost unit and that's what's
helping with your anxiety um but it's not going to really regenerate organs it's not going to do some
of the things that a high ghost machine would do so um but they're really expensive so you know we have
you know we we do sell a machine that goes up to about I think 8,000 ghosts but you're still going to
spend about 8,000 dollars for the machine so they get to be expensive um I do have a used one right now
if you're really interested if this is something you're really interested in so definitely contact me
um I have actually used professional high ghost machine um that I'd be willing to part with
that is um it's a really it's a good really good machine actually user hold but they're just
they're pricey um and if a person has got you know I have patients that just don't have financial
issues and they're like all by this machine all by this machine all by this and they basically
have more equipment in their house than I am in my office and that's great if you can do that I think
we're moving into a time where it's very difficult to trust any practitioners and if you have the
buddy to have devices in your house that's great but I everybody could do that but I get it so then
what do you do you triage what's the most important thing if you have cancer or right machine um and then
you go what's the second most important well it depends on what type of cancer you have brain cancer
that I'd get a HBOT machine so it you just kind of go through that list of you know what would be
the most important devices have you know hyperthermia pdf uh HBOT you know different different things
like that you kind of go through what would be you know it depends on your budget so yes you can
call them they can play with me and I'll gladly discuss that with okay any other questions you can
chat them in otherwise um I apologize for the late start and um we'll get this recorded up
well we'll see you guys next week have a blessed weekend and enjoy the winter wonderland out there
all right bye bye